[Music]
it is a generation absorbing the impact
of an era defining monarch
where the queen once walked her son must
now follow and here in australia
it is a turning point
we just loved her we just loved it the
older we got
the more we could relate to her because
she felt like she was just always there
for us i'm just like a lot of other
older australians we're just grieving
because
she was the queen of australia a lot of
people that's lost on a lot of people it
felt like the queen was almost um
immortal at some point you know she
she's lived a long time and yeah i mean
even
though she
was quite old when she passed it still
came as a shock
she was the first reigning monarch to
visit these shores
[Music]
it was 1954 she stayed for 58 days and
left a population spellbound
i want to tell you all
how happy i am to be amongst you
and how much i look forward to my
journey through australia
such outburst of spontaneous affection
she loves this country she loved this
country i should say
she'd been here 16 times and you don't
do that if you don't like the place and
she came back again and again and again
and she found the same thing again and
again again warmth affection
i think she really admired the
resilience of australians
who work and live off the land here it's
very nice to see you in person this time
yes your majesty
scott morrison admired her ability to
make light work of calming his nerves
she had he says a regal humility
that's why you know it's a cliche we'll
never see it like again but
we won't
where do you see that relationship
with the crown going there does remain a
strong connection and an appreciation
i mean our success in australia
is in no small part
due to the stability of our democracy of
our constitutional system and the crown
sits at the heart of that
but it has already had a referendum on
becoming a republic
and that conversation could reanimate
whatever debate has and may yet rage
around australia's relationship with the
monarchy this is being recognized as a
period of remembrance and respect and in
a febrile world that
feels strikingly rare
their love for the institution has waned
over time but not their love for the
queen
that appears enduring
audience sky news sydney australia